Неспокійний час для українських олігархів розпочався фактично з приходом
нової американської адміністрації. 11 січня США піддали санкціям бізнесмена
Андрія Деркача та ще низку осіб, зокрема народного депутата Олександра Дубінського -
неофіційної правої руки Ігоря Коломойського у парламенті.
Згодом Рада нацбезпеки та оборони заблокувала роботу телеканалів олігарха Віктора Медведчука
та компаній його правої руки Тараса Козака. У лютому НАБУ, за погодженням з генпрокуратурою,
оголосило підозру в розтраті чужого майна трьом колишнім топменеджерам "Приватбанку".
А 5 березня Ігорю Коломойському та його родині заборонили в'їзд до США -
через обвинувачення у корупційних оборудках у 2014-2015 роках.
Чи варто тепер чекати закручування гайок для Медведчука, Коломойського і Ко також з Брюсселю?
І чи будуть в Україні - услід за санкціями проти Медведчука - також санкції проти Коломойського?
Офіційний Євросоюз підтримує санкції США щодо Ігоря Коломойського, заявив
речник ЄС Петер Стано. Утім, у Брюсселі не схильні перебільшувати їхнє значення.
Активи Коломойського у США не заморожені. Набагато важливіше, на думку аналітиків,
чим Київ доповнить сигнал Вашингтона.
Це радше сигнал від адміністрації Байдена,
що Вашингтон буде уважно дивитися на боротьбу з корупцією в Україні
та деолігархізацію і що США готові до вживання конкретних кроків
для підтримки України в цій боротьбі. Але є й певні очікування від України в цьому зв’язку.
Санкції США проти Коломойського та його родини дуже цікаві.
Те, що Коломойський корумпований, усім відомо. Але українська влада
ще не порушувала проти нього якихось справ. І зараз все виглядає дуже дивно.
Нацбанк представив усі необхідні документи до прокуратури
щодо Коломойського та його партнера Боголюбова у грудні 2017-го.
І новий генпрокурор не порушив справи проти них. Тому ситуація доволі дивна,
і мені дуже цікаво, який вибір зробить українська влада.
Офіс президента у відповідь на оголошення американських санкцій повідомив,
що "за неповні два роки президентства Володимира Зеленського було зроблено
у рази більше деолігархізації України, ніж будь-ким з попередніх президентів".
У Європі це зрозуміли так, що швидкого наступу на Коломойського не варто чекати.
Інакше це прокоментував би президент Зеленський особисто,
а не його прессекретарка, і меседж був би значно вагомішим.
Зеленський ніколи не казав жодного негативного слова про Коломойського.
Очевидно, що він залежний від Коломойського. Не знаю як, але те,
що лояльні до Коломойського депутати перебувають у фракції партії Зеленського,
означає, що він дуже залежний від Коломойського.
Європейці відзначають той факт, що поки немає явних ознак впливу олігархів на самого президента Зеленського
та корупції на найвищому рівні. Але разом з тим багато хто розчарований невиконанням його реформаторських обіцянок.
Багато українських лідерів обіцяли побороти олігархів, але це виявилося доволі важко.
Адже їхній вплив вкорінився дуже глибоко, і його позбутися важко, бо це загрожує ускладненнями для керівництва країни.
Не думаю, що така ж ситуація із Зеленським. Він мені здається доволі незаплямованим.
Він не корумпований, наскільки нам відомо. Але в окремих випадках олігархи мають змогу впливати на президента.
Те, що ситуація для тіньових оборудок не стала менш сприятливою, підтверджують і інші спостерігачі.
Їм видається, що олігархи нині почуваються не гірше, ніж за Порошенка.
Олігархи почуваються краще. Оскільки Порошенко сам був олігархом, вони були для нього конкурентами.
А зараз два найвпливовіших олігархи - це Ахметов та Коломойський.
Особливо Коломойський. У Коломойського щонайменше 30 депутатів у Верховній Раді, у партії президента.
Зеленський та його команда відмовилися від співпраці з активістами громадського сектору,
які активно працювали за Порошенка. Тобто не було створено коаліції реформаторів,
як тоді, проти старої системи та проти влади олігархів.
І тому в багатьох сферах утворюється простір для людей, які, на мою думку, представляють інтереси олігархів.
І це або відновлює їх сфери їхнього впливу, або відкриває їм
нові, у порівнянні з тим, як було кілька років тому.
У Європі вважають, що Україні не обов'язково оголошувати "хрестові походи" проти конкретних олігархів,
натомість слід продовжити реформу правосуддя, аби суди перестали бути інструментом у руках олігархів.
Потрібно захистити незалежність НАБУ та інших слідчих інститутів,
натомість позбавити СБУ функції з розслідування економічних злочинів,
завершити реформу прокуратури, провести прозорі конкурси до САП та ДБР,
зміцнювати незалежність Нацбанку та антимонопольне законодавство тощо.
Домашніх завдань багато, і більшість з них не виконуються Києвом.
Верховенство закону - велика проблема для України. Ви можете захистити
своє майно, лише якщо ви є олігархом. Якщо ви не олігарх,
ви не можете захистити своє майно. І нічого не було зроблено,
аби реформувати цю грабіжницьку державну машину.
США зробили Ігоря Коломойського опальною особою.
Але чи будуть у мільярдера проблеми й у Європейському Союзі?
Судячи з розмов, які DW провела у Європарламенті та серед експертів щодо України, радше ні.
Ідею запровадити санкції проти українського олігарха, аналогічні американським,
в Євросоюзі поки не обговорювали.
Ці санкції, за словами аналітиків, будуть можливі за двох умов.
По-перше, якщо буде ретельно обґрунтоване звернення від Києва,
а його поки не реєстрували. По-друге, якщо не корупцію загалом,
а конкретний злочин особи буде "залізно" доведено, аби вона не могла потім
оскаржити санкції. Євросоюз став куди обережнішим щодо економічних
санкцій загалом, адже не може собі дозволити нових програшів у судах
за позовами від підсанкційних осіб, як це було з оточенням Януковича.
Досі питання санкцій проти Коломойського не було темою в Євросоюзі.
На мою думку, що стосується Коломойського та інших українських олігархів,
ЄС очікує насамперед від української влади ухвалення
законодавства, яке обмежить вплив олігархів в Україні.
Європейські експерти вітають крок Києва щодо обмеження впливу Віктора Медведчука.
Але попри це песимізм поки переважає.
Досі мільярдеру Коломойському ніщо не заважає вести справи в Україні.
Не зменшується тіньовий вплив на економіку й іншого бізнесмена -
Ріната Ахметова - та інших олігархів.
Водночас в оточенні Зеленського запевняють, що найближчим часом
зможуть показати добрі результати у реформуванні багатьох сфер,
особливо в судовій сфері та на ринку енергетики, де олігархи
традиційно збагачуються. Європа ж терпляче чекає.